STATE OF SAMSUNG:
Samsung’s operating profits
are falling off a cliff. Over the past year,
their quarterly profits have plummeted from
just over $10 billion down to just $490 million.
This represents a 95% cliff dive within just a
matter of a year and it’s the lowest numbers
that Samsung has reported since 2009. Normally,
this would be indicative of a failing company
like Nokia or Yahoo who’s numbers are down across
the board but that’s not quite the case
with Samsung. Take their top line numbers
for example. This too is down for Samsung from
$240 billion per year to $200 billion per year,
but that’s a much more modest drop of about 16% as
opposed to 95%. A similar story can be seen with
their smartphone shipments as well. While they
have been slowly bleeding dominance and sales,
nothing drastic has unfolded within the past
12 to 24 months. This puts Samsung in a really
weird situation where they’re not exactly losing
relevance but they are losing profitability. It’s
easy to write this off as just a market downturn
but when we peel back the layers, it becomes clear
that Samsung is facing a much larger crisis
due to the era of peak smartphone. So, join
me as we dive deeper into Samsung’s existential
crisis and their struggle to remain profitable.
ALL IN:
Speaking of a struggle to remain profitable,
many investors are struggling to remain profitable
in this era of high inflation and high interest
rates. More than ever, people are hoarding cash in
savings accounts and brokerage accounts to earn as
much interest as possible which is by no means a
bad strategy but it wont last forever. When the
Fed starts cutting rates, savings account interest
will naturally follow suit. One way to overcome
this decline, however, is to take advantage
of bonds. With bonds, you can lock in current
high interest rates for not just the next 6 to
12 months but for as long as 30 years. If that
sounds enticing, please consider checking
out our upcoming bond investing app, Silo,
in the description below. But anyway, a simple
Google search would tell you that the primary
culprit behind Samsung’s dwindling profits is
the memory chip market. If you didn’t know,
Samsung is not just a big memory chip producer,
they are the biggest memory chip producer. This
title definitely sounds impressive on paper but
Samsung actually had to make massive sacrifices
to get here like overbetting on the chip market.
You see, one of the ways that Samsung was able
to beat the competition and rise to the to top
was simply outspending the competition. In fact,
they’ve been doing this for decades dating as
far back as 1997. This year, Samsung opened
up a $1.3 billion memory chip fab in Austin TX.
Over the next 14 years, this would grow to being
a $9 billion investment which is not only one
of the largest chip investments in the world,
but one of the largest foreign investments the
US has ever seen. This sort of spending is what
allowed Samsung to catch up to and overtake the
competition but this is also a very dangerous game
because there is no moat when it comes to internal
components. You see, most end consumers don’t care
or even know what brand of chips is going into
their smartphones and computers and cars. So,
there’s virtually no brand loyalty and companies
like Apple just go with whoever is offering the
best performance and price at the time. Over the
past decade, this has very much been Samsung but
it doesn’t take long to fall behind within the
chip industry. Moore’s law may more may not be
dead but one thing is for sure, chips are still
advancing extremely fast. Even stagnating for
an year or two could destroy the lead that
took decades to build. So, year after year,
these chip producers are having to invest
more and more. Really, all of this is just one
massive game of chicken. Fortunately, Samsung
hasn’t dropped the ball when it comes to R&D,
they’ve actually been doing the exact opposite,
they’ve been stepping up to the plate. But,
this has simply led to ridiculous investments.
Just earlier this year, Samsung announced that
they would be investing, wait for it, $228 billion
to build the world’s largest chip facility. Let me
put this in perspective. That’s more than Apple
has spent on R&D across the entire company since
the launch of the iPhone itself. It’s hard to find
data about Apple’s R&D spending throughout the 80s
and 90s but it’s very likely that $228 billion
is more than Apple has spent on R&D throughout
their entire history. This honestly isn’t that
surprising given that $228 billion is enough money
to buy out a fortune 50 company cash. And Samsung
is looking to spend this much money on an industry
that they could lose at anytime within just a
matter of 2 years. This is no doubt a gutsy bet
but when you take a closer look at the companies
internals, it starts to become more clear why
Samsung is basically betting it all. It’s likely
that Samsung feels that they have no other choice.
This is probably a bit confusing because most
of us see Samsung as a giant conglomerate with
strongholds in dozens of industries. They make
everything from smartphones, chips, monitors,
laptops, and TVs to refrigerators, dishwashers,
washing machines, and who knows what else. But,
while they do indeed have their hands in
every business you can think of, almost 60%
of their profits came from just one sector:
semiconductors. So, it’s not surprising why
Samsung is willing to make such a massive gamble
chip fabrication. It’s their bread and butter and
they can’t afford to lose. But, one thing they’re
forgetting is that just because they stay on top
of the chip industry doesn't mean that they’ll
actually stay on top overall. Let me explain.
VOLATILITY STRIKES:
If large amounts of capital
and a lack of a moat weren’t bad enough, another
major pitfall of the chip industry is that it’s
one of the most cyclical industries in the world
and pandemic simply exacerbated this effect. I
think we all remember how tech was a bit hard to
come by back in 2020 and 2021. PS5s and graphics
cards were basically impossible to come by. Often
times you had to pay 2-3 times the price just
to buy these gadgets and it wasn’t just tech
products either. Anything that even slightly
had to do with chips were extremely hard to
come by including cars and even refrigerators
which often had waiting times in the 6-12 month
range. As such, all of these products naturally
rocketed in price. Most people just figured that
these price increases where due to high inflation
but a lot of it just had to do with the global
chip shortage. You see, when the pandemic hit,
most chip fabricators either pulled back or
completely shut down temporarily due to covid
restrictions and general uncertainty. At the same
time, the demand for these products went through
the roof. Everyone was staying at home meaning
that they were more dependent on electronics
than ever. Moreover, they weren’t spending any
money on vacations or eating out or any of that,
so they were able to spend a lot more on tech.
This led to this extreme situation where there was
no supply and massive demand leading to ridiculous
revenue and profit margins for chip makers. Many
chip makers including Samsung assumed that this
was simply the new norm for the modern hybrid
economy but it hasn’t quite played out that way.
In fact prices for tech products are very much
falling off a cliff as supply and demand have more
or less normalized. Take Tesla prices for example.
In the peak of the chip shortage in late 2021
and early 2022, Model X prices reached as high
as $108,000. But, over the past 18 months, prices
have almost halved down to $63,000. This is great
for consumers as some prices are finally returning
to reality but for Samsung, this is a nightmare.
In fact, normalizing supply and demand have led to
DRAM prices plummeting by 53% year over year. And
experts don’t think the pain is over either, so
we could very well by looking at a 60% plus price
drop before things finally stabilize. Given that
60% of Samsung’s profits were coming from chips,
it’s no wonder why their bottom line has been
obliterated. The reality is that profits from
their chip business have not only gone down,
they’ve actually become negative. In fact,
over the first 6 months of 2023, Samsung took a
$7 billion loss on their chip business. Samsung
is of course trying to cut production to prop
up prices as much as they can but unfortunately,
demand is falling even faster. You see, it’s
not just prices that have been plummeting,
demand has also been plummeting as companies and
consumers have become much more conservative with
tech spending due to high inflation
and recession fears. Not to mention,
most people just got a bunch of new tech over
the past few years so they don’t exactly feel
the need to upgrade which brings us into a
bigger question: Will Samsung ever recover?
ERA OF PEAK SMARTPHONE:
Normally, the answer would just be yes.
Eventually, when the chip industry enters another
boom cycle, Samsung should naturally recover. But,
here’s an interesting point to consider: not all
of the chip industry is getting destroyed. In
fact, certain sectors within the chip industry
are doing better than ever specifically AI. I
don’t even need to explain this, I mean,
just take a look at Nvidia’s stock graph,
it’s vertical. Granted the stock market is very
much being irrational with Nvidia but it’s not
like Nvidia’s doing bad fundamentally either. In
fact, they just posted their largest quarterly
profit of all time coming in at $6 billion.
Of course, Nvidia is an exception case who
has largely benefited from the AI boom. Everyone
focused on traditional chip making like Samsung,
TSMC, AMD, and Intel have seen their margins get
obliterated, but this brings up a larger question:
where exactly does Samsung fit within the era of
peak smartphone. While it’s true that Samsung has
made massive advancements with mobile chips and
memory over the past 15 years, a lot of their
success is actually just thanks to the success
of the smartphone industry at large. This was
great in the early to mid 2010s when smartphones
sales were exploding, but over the past 5 years,
smartphone sales have started to fall quite
noticeably. And the more time that passes,
the more likely it feels that smartphones are
destined for the same fate as PCs. As PC sales
started to fall, manufacturers naturally started
competing on price. Of course, there were some
exceptions like Apple and some higher end product
lines from Dell and Asus. But, for the most part,
the PC industry became a race to the bottom and
profit magins edged closer and closer to 0. Many
reputable manufacturers like Sony and Toshiba
actually just exited the business altogether.
And many of the survivors like Dell and HP started
focusing on other parts of their business like the
cloud and servers. They simply kept around their
laptops and PCs as a way to maintain their brand
presence as opposed to drive massive profits.
This same thing is starting to happen with
smartphone brands as well. In early 2021, for
example, LG left the smartphone business after
losing money for 23 consecutive quarters.
The same thing happened to HTC, Microsoft,
and Nokia as well. Heck even Apple isn’t immune.
In fact, that’s why they stopped reporting iPhone
sales 5 years ago. And with how disappointing
the iPhone 15 is, who knows how bad sales will
be. But, with that being said, Apple will do
just fine because they’ve shifted their focus to
monetizing the use of the iPhone as opposed to the
purchase of the iPhone. The same, however, cannot
be said about Samsung. Samsung phones run Android
meaning that it’s mainly Google that profits from
the use of Samsung’s 2 billion phones. Samsung is
still very much dependent on the sales of their
own smartphones and other smartphones for which
they make internal components. And as smartphones
become more and more commoditized, this business
will become less and less viable. This isn’t to
say that Samsung is on the brink of collapse or
something but the point is that this isn’t just
a downturn for Samsung. Rather it’s very much a
test regarding whether Samsung can grow and evolve
past smartphones. Can they capitalize on the AI
trend? Can they shift to monetizing the use of
Samsung phones? Can they reduce their dependency
on smartphone components? These are the concerns
that Samsung will have to address in the coming
years if they want to grow past the era of peak
smartphone. Will Samsung be able to make this jump
or will they end up like the next IBM? Only time
will tell. If you’d like to take advantage of
high interest rates and have the government and
top companies pay you 4-7%, check out our upcoming
bond investing app Silo in the description below.